[Music]
welcome back to another exciting episode
of Kos and this character that we're
about to talk about next
it's probably one of my best characters
when I was younger um it intrigued me
because of the level of fear that he
will instill in the criminals and he's a
very underrated character where you
really wouldn't know his powers if you
weren't outside you know of the comic
book world looking in you would just
think that he's a hothead riding a
motorcycle I give you none other then
iron Studios exclusive 1/10 art scale
budget line Ghost Rider
you see the size and you can tell by the
pictures that will be popping up
periodically the level of detail on
their art skills are tremendous and the
value that you get for this level of
detail is incredible
I believe he topped out at 165
very solid piece comes in an irregular
shipper box the box was fantastic as you
can see here it has chains around it
like the you know the whatchamacallit of
vengence the spirit of vengence and also
at the top it has the revamped
ghostwriter logo now I'm going to get
into that in a second but what I really
want to talk about more is the level of
unboxing because this is the unboxing
video ok the level of unboxing is
treated as like a premium format statute
whereas the base comes trapped in the
bottom as you can see and the pieces are
well thought out individually packed and
sealed and wrapped so that we ship
mantilla on your art scale gets you it
gets to you in great condition no
breakage very beautiful I thought this
statute
was incredible and immediately it sold
out on sideshows website and I've seen a
lot of these dudes online these
resellers online doing the kink the
community a disservice by selling them
for five six hundred dollars you heard
me right a statue that I got for 160 165
they're selling it for five six hundred
dollars that's sad
so if you missed out on the pre-order
I'm sorry there are a couple of ghost
rider on bikes the best one that you can
get is the XM volts rider on bike that's
the one I want so bad that statue I want
so bad but it's $3,000 and you have to
make sure that you have the space for XM
statue you have to make sure that you
know it's in value you understand
there's a bowing on bike and there's the
iron studio on bike this is the only one
I believe that is a Danny ketch now
we're going to get into the comic book
talk of the segment
a lot of you guys know Johnny Blaze and
a lot of you guys know ghost rider from
the MC use movie the Ghost Rider
starring Nicolas Cage
I thought Nicolas Cage portrayed my
character that I loved so much so well
it's well known that Nicolas Cage is a
comic book enthusiast where he loves
Superman and he was slated to play
Superman and it didn't happen
but I'm so thankful that he did get a
chance to play one of my iconic
characters that I grew up reading now
what they did in that movie is they
merged the two looks
they used the old school bike and merged
it with the Danny ketch votes writer not
as two ghost riders well there's more
there's more people that has been
possessed by the spirit of vengeance but
the two iconic characters is Danny ketch
and Johnny Blaze Johnny Blaze is the
original run Danny catches the second
one
Mephisto actually embodied the spirit of
vengeance in those two characters now
Danny ketch has two better-looking suit
with the spikes and in Chains and he
showed a more dynamic range of power
when it came to the Ghost Rider his bike
was more of a centerpiece than an add-on
that's why you see the robustness of the
bike when you see in the pitches in the
art that you see on the screen so I
always felt that the Danny ketch version
which got me back into reading Ghost
Rider was probably the best Ghost Rider
for me
and I always felt that that reignited
the feel of Ghost Rider
in the public because after that the
Ghost Rider took off you know he's in -
he was in the Fantastic Four he was in
the Avengers so I thought Ghost Rider
actually became more relevant in this
day and age because of the new art
direction mark texture was the artist
that drew the I think it was the second
like the revamping of the character and
how he fits in the MC new MCU now as you
see him on the show agents of shield you
know with the Ghost Rider and they're
using the modern version of the Ghost
Rider the spirit of vengeance is I think
he's invaded somebody of Hispanic
heritage and he rides a car and that's
that's wonderful
I'm not too familiar with that character
because it really didn't interest me
to that extent you know I really do and
we are about stuff that really
interested me but when this came up for
pre-order I couldn't crew order it fast
enough and it sold out I think within a
day it was gone and if you go to the
website it's gone
the level of detail from the flames to
the face the bike
even the platform that it comes in if
you look right here you can see the
platform is a street gravel pavement
with skid marks of the pavement being
melted by the bike side swiping
[Music]
beautiful level of detail extreme amount
of value in this art piece this statue
is utterly amazing
it fits almost anywhere and this also
shows you don't have to break the bank
to get bang for your buck the budget
line art skill is made for everyone a
lot of times people ask me do King you
know these statues cost so much and I
want to get in I don't have the space on
our scale line is available
I am studios is catering to our pockets
and also our tastes if you want to have
a bunch of statues displayed for the
maximum amount of dollar the maximum
amount of space that you can use and the
level of detail and wow fact that you
have when people come in amazing utter
ly amazing what they have done and what
they have achieved so without further
ado we're gonna go into the law and the
difference
of this odd scale Danny catch Ghost
Rider the spikes that you see on the
character is great the chain that you
see on the wrist is actually real chain
it came separate and I had to unbox it
and put it on his hand and wrap it
around his wrist and let it hang
beautiful touch its touches like that
then let you know the company went the
extra mile for you ooh that is fantastic
[Music]
we're gonna show more pictures more
video but this is the part of the video
when I asked you to like follow
subscribe and also go to Lords of gaming
dotnet where we have a ton of opinion
pieces we have combat talk with the king
yourself ah oh boy it's crazy how we
just got back from play NYC with play
crafting of New York City it was an
amazing show we have tons of video up
tons of coverage up where a lot of
people don't have this coverage this
coverage is that loads of gaming dotnet
so go to Lords of gaming dinette check
out all the new video games coming out
check out all the tons of opinion pieces
get old Kos episodes that you can read
upon you can get the dimensions of this
statue see if it fits your on your space
and then I'm pretty sure to fit your
budget because it is a great value also
you can see our reviews up there with
Lourdes attic he has a ton of reviews up
this guy is playing games at a rapid
pace and he's given his opinion and he's
given his reviews
on how he feels the games are also you
can get the last word with Lord kognito
and Eve on ttis destiny is heating up is
that a fever pitch and we also have a
ton a ton of division talk with apex
legends and a lot of other looters
shooters remember Borderlands is coming
Borderlands 3 so you want to be with
Lords of gimmick dotnet so you can get
all that information on those looters
shooters that you love remember to stick
around so you can see more of what we
have and remember last week when I told
you this one came in the box well this
is what came in the box what was in the
box right Ghost Rider
couldn't stop don't forget my inception
video with a video within a video
explaining the breakage and sometimes
how tragedies may happen to your statues
that's on its way
because replacement statues are here
we're going to go into all of that stuff
there's a lot of statues to go have a
lot on pre-order also have a lot Upton
display that I haven't even showed you
yet so we're gonna get to that stuff
we're gonna enjoy the ride and thank you
again all the likes all the views
everything about you guys makes me want
to do this even more and makes it worth
it thank you again leave comments so I
can improve this also the decoys gonna
prove improve soon got my [ __ ] putting
it together all my boxes going in the
shed more space I have a new statue um
coming up and that's gonna be even more
amazing so stick around listen to this
great music watch the video watch the
the pitches and enjoy yourself see you
next week
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]